man there is so much I want to talk
about in this video this is one of those
reviews I I just have to accept the fact
that it's never going to feel complete
it's just going to get uploaded also
letting you know this is going to be a
spoiler-free review for the Spider-Man 2
game I will talk about you know what
villains are in it things that you've
seen in the promotional material also in
a world where Insomniac games came out
and told the world who Venom is not
before the game even came out I'll talk
about who Venom is not but I'm not going
to tell you who Venom is because I feel
like that's a reveal you're supposed to
experience as The Story Goes On maybe
you find it obvious I don't know but in
a world where I got to talk about Venom
here I'd rather air on the side of
caution with that all right here we
[Music]
go so Spider-Man 2 is insomniac PS5
exclusive very successful sequel to the
very successful Spider-Man you have
Peter Parker Spider-Man Miles Morales a
Spider-Man you get to play as both
craving the hunter come to New York for
the good hunt Peter Parker gets the
symbiote suit and everything that leads
to to New York is bigger than it was
before once again you do feel like you
are New York's protector no matter who
you are is Spider-Man that's one of the
things I liked on the Fly you can swap
between Peter Parker or Miles Morales
some of the side missions are specific
to one Spider-Man or the other but when
you're generally going through the city
taking down criminals you can pick
whoever you want that's awesome that
they know there are fans of both people
want to be who they want to be and I
felt this game did a really good job at
balancing the importance of the
Spider-Man would have been easy to be
like yeah equal to Peter Parker story
and the DLC guy I know he's not DLC got
his own game I'm just saying it could
have felt like that but this does feel
like a team effort miles has some great
story arcs just for him personally plus
when you as Peter get the symbiote suit
it's what you know about the Symbio suit
feels really cool at first and then it
becomes a problem because Peter Parker
becomes an I like the fact that
even when Peter is an you still
play as him it can be immersion breaking
I felt like I was supposed to do some of
the side missions before I went on with
the story so the story Peter's becoming
much more hardcore and then I'll go and
take out a bunch of criminals and he's
like hey just doing my job New York
friendly neighborhood Spider-Man also
the blood the slaughter he doesn't say
that but you know what I mean so I like
that you get to play as more hardcore
Spider-Man also you get to see it
Through The Eyes of Miles Morales which
is my friend he's changing and I feel
like he's in trouble it balanced the
themes you have villains that play off
of the themes in the game like you take
the lizard Dr Connor is a victim of the
lizard he's essentially a hostage of the
lizard when the lizard is out as Peter
Parker is a hostage of the symbiote suit
though he doesn't quite know it yet also
the dude I got it the dialogue when I
was fighting the lizard was epic cuz
your symbiote suit Spider-Man starts
becoming a bit more of a dick and I'm
fighting the lizard he's like no wonder
your family left you I was
like L blow dude but in order to
Traverse this more enormous New York you
now have new abilities namely the web
gliders you can glide around like your
Batman or some you got some good
updrafts to keep you in the air some jet
streams you can find to make it faster
cuz there were moments where I was like
is gliding truly faster than web
swinging you find one of those jet
streams the answer is a resounding yes
also at a point fast travel unlocks it
does it per section you have to do
enough missions in any given section and
then fast travel unlocks for that
section and fast travels awesome it just
it looks cool you can aim the cursor at
any point on the map in a section you
have unlocked fast travel 4 hold that
button down the map becomes reality and
in you go in terms of gameplay the
fighting very familiar to what you know
from the previous Spider-Man game the
combos are very familiar I will say this
game in terms of combat was much easier
than the previous Spider-Man game it's
probably because they inundate you with
so many Tech and special abilities you
essentially have eight that you can do
even if you run into one of the big guys
it's supposed to be a big problem you
can hit him with one of your Tech
abilities that'll stun him you start
comboing him he snaps out of it you hit
him with another one you start comboing
him rinse and repeat at a point you
figure that out they cease to really be
a problem but also in terms of just the
general multitasking I felt the first
Spider-Man game had a lot more you had
to keep your head on a swivel floor a
lot more enemies with rocket launchers
if I'm stacking it up taking out a base
in Spider-Man was much more difficult
than taking out a base in Spider-Man 2
you have a myriad of side missions in
here you have the sciency things no
longer a 2d puzzle I like puzzle
mechanic side missions I just do give me
those Bioshock one puzzles all day long
I just get a kick out of them this one
the puzzles are far easier but you do
have puzzles nonetheless feel like
that's a big theme in Spider-Man 2 in
every real sense I can think of the game
is easier fighting groups of enemies is
easier the bosses are easier the puzzles
are easier the platinum trophy itself is
easier but for the side mission some are
fun some are lame I have myself to blame
I just wasn't connecting with the whole
Miles Morales helping his high school
out so I finished those missions up when
the was hitting the fan and I was
like oh by the way let me help you with
those yearbook photos you do it and
they're like oh by the way uh can you
take three more pictures oh by the way
when you're done with that can you just
swing around the school presumptuous
dicks but I helped them out did it
because I need that platinum trophy and
you do have missions where you play as
Mary Jane and here yes you remember
Spider-Man 1 those MJ missions that just
ground the momentum of the game to a
halt there are missions in Spiderman 2
where you play as Mary Jane I will say
though the game play much more engaging
and exciting not saying I buy the fact
of Mary Jane Watson sneaking up on and
taking out a squad of Craven Hunters
don't give me that I'm being sexist
you know it doesn't make a lot of sense
most people wouldn't be able to do that
that's my point I was going through that
thing like I was Roar Shack or some
one do you seem to understand I'm not
locked in here with
you you're locked in here with me I will
reiterate though the MJ gameplay much
more fun this time around and I'll take
fun over sneaking around slog Fest one
of the new and absurdly fun abilities
you get in this game is the ability to
make this little web Highwire you can
walk out on take enemies out from above
via stealth but you can also like aim it
up and create web ramp High wires and
dude by the end I was just looking
around I'm like this looks like a spider
layer it's not like the Arkham games the
Arkham games people you get spotted and
they're shooting at you you go across a
couple gargoyles people like ah I
where you go he's right here I it was
like he was here and then he he went
that way and he just became invisible
Spider-Man's like no I saw you I could
see you doing that too what are you
doing it's not as easy to escape I found
that fun that makes the stealth kills
more gratifying and fulfilling when you
pull them off when you clear out a whole
room you just feel badass but the
villains man I got to tell you this I
feel really bad for Aaron Taylor Johnson
at this point because what you get in
here is craving Prime Craven's great in
here first of all he's coming to New
York to hunt Spider-Man's enemies
because he's like that's the real game
right there he's this apex predator who
lives for the hunt Spider-Man has some
very huntworthy villains out there I
stress villains because that was such a
cool part of this game you have to
protect your enemies from another enemy
because Spider-Man's like I'm not about
killing people unless Jeremy's playing
as Spider-Man I heard that you can go
around the building and you see them web
to the building that broke my heart all
right fine I'll save my blood Lust For
The Wolverine game whatever but you
don't just get Craven it's not like he's
this guy who comes into the city I mean
he is but it's the Craven culture you
get you really feel like this guy's
entire life and sense of being is all
about the hunt in a very Primal sense
you get it you understand it that's so
cool also the symbiote suit the symbiote
suit is in and of itself its own story
it's dealing with also a villain a
villain posing as a friend there's so
much cool power to be had by wearing the
symbiote suit but my God they do such a
great job at illustrating that this suit
is a parasite it's not a symbiotic
relationship it's a parasitic
relationship it's taking far more than
it gives it gives you the illusion of
getting something but in the end you are
simply a host for its will that's always
been the story of the Symbiote soup but
when you have hours of gaml fleshing
this out it just hits different it hits
deeper I even love the aesthetic of the
suit where you look a little deeper and
you can tell it's moving a little bit it
is a living epidermis and then at a
point Peter really starts losing himself
to this thing and it just looks like a
straight up alien skin I just got a
deeper sense of how one loses themselves
to this parasite via the alteration of
their brain chemistry it's wild how at
the whim of our brain chemistry we are
this game actually doesn't
scientifically go into it like this but
in terms of what I could see through the
characters that's really how it landed
with me where it's more than you just
become an version of yourself
who creates memes for the rest of the
internet's life I mean '90s me was all
about Venom the symbiot suit it's what I
lived for in Spider-Man back when so
I've seen more than a few iterations of
this I just felt this one was a very
clear picture of what this thing's doing
to him for my life of Spider-Man fandom
I've always been like yeah but man if I
got that symbiote suit that'd be awesome
like Eddie Brock being like no you're
going to listen to me and we're going to
be anti-heroes you get the sense that
that's really not how this works here
that is a delusion it'll make you think
so it can just kind of take you over as
for Venom yes Venom is also in the game
as Insomniac said Eddie Brock is not
Venom in this game what the hell I will
be honest with you the arc they have for
Venom is actually a really good one man
Venom is aggressive in this game that's
when the really starts hitting the
fan it's when all that stuff I said
before about like oh yeah the fights are
easy well I mean it's still easy but it
does crank up the intensity at a point
in the game there's actually a scene
with Venom that very much reminded me of
the Hulk in The Avengers movie angry and
bloodthirsty more importantly angry at
you also Tony Todd is
Venom come on we're going to kill the
world that's a layup that's god tier I
will say if there are fundamentalists
out there who like no Eddie Brock needs
to be Venom he's probably going to
bother you but I actually I do get I
have my weird Boomer energy gripes for
this game like everyone in Miles
morales's life and Peter Parker's life
all know that they are the Spider-Man
they don't need to hide it from their
friends and loved ones not like the
world knows but their friends they know
in terms of fundamental lessons of life
I mean there's a good argument to be
like yeah open communication with your
friends that's a healthy thing I
wouldn't be surprised if that was
exactly the conversation and the reason
that said if I were a superhero I
wouldn't tell anybody just saying but it
has officially been 15 years since Iron
Man mainstreamed the idea of not hiding
behind the mask that is to say a child
who was born when Tony Stark ended his
film with I am Iron Man telling the
world who he was this will differ
depending on state or country but for
looking at about 15 years that child
born will be able to get a learner's
permit to drive a car it's been some
time so I feel like anyone between the
ages of 1 and 30 are not going to give a
but when I see it I'm like oh I
missed that
it's a fundamental thing of the
superhero's journey in his life looking
the in Spider-Man 2 it's great but what
you really want to know is is it better
than the first game it is bigger than
the first game no doubt that's not even
a question better not for me I feel like
that's a hot take but I felt the first
game was just in the zone 100% of the
time except the MJ side quest this
definitely hasn't over one there no
doubt first game was more challenging on
every level where you really feel it of
the fight scenarios I I just felt the
first Spider-Man game forced me to
change up my tactics more than two two
for most of the game launch the enemy in
the air either with an uppercut or a web
swing kick then juggle them in the air
with air combat when you knock them out
hold triangle web the next person pull
them up into the air air combat them
there were battles there were fights in
this game My Feet never touched the
ground if an enemy is too big to web
into the air don't worry you have a lot
of tech to dispatch that enemy with also
a lot of tech to take out the bosses
with however they're telling a very
complex and personal story in Spider-Man
2 not that the first one didn't have
that really personal story between Peter
and Doc O and it th in tears by the
end but whereas in the Final Act of
these games it gets bigger I felt in
Spider-Man 2 it got too big I was like I
don't require that this game like the
last was at its best when it was really
hammering home that more personal story
and that story in here the story of
Peter Parker and the power you feel with
the symbiot suit and then the damaging
presence in Peter's life it becomes all
the while your Miles Morales seeing your
friend go through this Spider-Man 2
deserves all the props for existing in a
world in which these Spider-Man stories
for both heroes and villains have been
told many times over over the course of
decades so they go a different direction
with these stories for the sake of them
feeling new but they also do the
characters and their arcs Justice that
for me is the gold and that's what makes
it worth buying at full price which is
funny cuz full price is more now game
prices are going up physical media is
going away I got to rethink the
structure of my entire rating system all
right so Spider-Man 2 have you played it
what did you think about it whatever you
thought comment below let me know also
spoiler warning for the comment section
if you haven't played the game you
should probably steer clear of that and
as always if you like what you've seen
here and you want to see more click
right here to see
[Music]
more